the Panama Canal is one of History's
great feats of engineering connecting
the Atlantic and the Pacific the canal
represented a major change in trade
between East and West saving time for
many states and damaging the economies
of others it was finished by the United
States in 1914 and these lands in Panama
around the canal are under U.S
sovereignty until 1999 because in 1977
President Jimmy Carter had agreed to
return it to Panama in return for
exactly nothing but given how useful
controlling the canal was especially
during the Cold War why did the United
States do this why did the USA give up
the Panama Canal for free so since
Europeans had first discovered the new
world they had dreamed of building a
canal straight through Central America
it never happened because digging is
quite hard and digging through a
continent is even harder this didn't
stop the French from stepping up in the
late 19th century though since they had
just finished building the much longer
Suez Canal the problem with this canal
was the environment disease and terrain
meant that the cost of building the
canal soon spiraled out of control and
it wasn't long until the French gave up
in Step the USA under Theodore
roosevelty wanted to finish the canal to
expand U.S influence in the region his
Government tried to strike a deal with
the Colombian government but they said
no this forced him to respect their
wishes and oh wait no rebels in the
north of the country the panamanians had
revolted to achieve independence and the
U.S decided that it was going to help
them providing that they got the canal
and control over the territory around it
and the new Panama government said yes
since without U.S support Colombia would
have reconquered the country the canal
was finished in 1914 and it remained
under U.S control until 1999. during
this time the canal had been incredibly
useful especially in World War II when
it allowed U.S ships to easily cross
between the Atlantic and the Pacific and
the US also used it to block communist
warships in the Cold War plus over the
decades the transit fee to use the canal
had made the US government lots of money
yet in 1977 after Decades of
negotiations President Carter agreed to
a phased Handover of the Canal Zone back
to Panama in return for nothing so why
well there were several reasons the
first was diplomacy with the rest of the
Americas American control of the Canal
Zone particularly the military bases
which were there to protect it was seen
imperialist by most nations in Central
and South America that and the Suez
Crisis from a couple of decades earlier
had cemented the idea that the world's
Waterway should be neutral Carter wanted
to return the canal to Panama to assure
the rest of the Americas that the United
States was going to be a good neighbor
and to also make sure that they wouldn't
make friends with the USSR which brings
us to point number two competition part
of the 1977 treaty stipulated that the
US would make the canal neutral to All
Nations which meant letting communist
navies use it too Carter agreed to this
because he was concerned that the USSR
would Finance another canal in either
Southern Panama or potentially Nicaragua
as such agreeing to had it over in 20
years meant that building another Canal
wouldn't be worth it and furthermore the
U.S could keep collecting Transit fees
during that time the third reason was
military the Panama Canal was important
to American Naval strategy since it
allowed for quick redeployment of his
ships to different oceans however in the
days of nuclear weapons and ballistic
missiles it was no longer as important
as such takarta's Administration the
cost of keeping the canal outweighed the
benefits and it was decided that it
would be handed over and after this
despite some grumblings the USA was
treaty bound to hand over the canal a
process which would be completed by the
end of the Millennium which meant that
after this Panama would go from being
politically cut in half to just
geographically I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons James
bisonnet Kelly moneymaker call show wolf
Jordan Longley Adams daughter Jerry
lambdin Marcus arsner why in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot words about books
podcast Gustav Swann Captain psydog rod
D Martin commune boogly Wiggly Mrs ET
Marvin cassau Aaron the white Matthew
Shipley Alex Schwinn Maggie Paskowski
Anthony Beckett Max and flaudio the
mcwoper Corey Turner spinning three
plates Coppertone Winston caywood
Charles the first and Scottish Trekkie